But a very,
very good evening to you,
delighted to have professor Stiglitz
with us and it's fantastic that
economics can put in such a big crowd.
Um,
British economist,
a pretty good,
uh,
by global standards,
American economists to somehow more
interesting.
I always tend to think they,
they have a tradition of saying things
that people can understand writing in
newspapers being polemical and
political,
uh,
and also winning Nobel prizes.
Joe Stiglitz is in this tradition.
He's written this book,
the latest of his books,
highly readable,
uh,
available,
from the foyer I should say.
Um,
but he's also worked in the real world.
Well,
the sort of real worlds,
the World Bank,
the Clinton administration.
Um,
but he's achieved top academic
distinction with a Nobel prize which he
got with several others for spotting
something quite important in economics.
Um,
and indeed in life that information is
extremely important and that markets
don't always work well when information
is unequally distributed.
If a lender doesn't know how reliable
that borrower is,
the market for loans may not work well.
Now,
that's something that might perhaps
sound a bit obvious now,
but the arguments are quite subtle.
It's around the fact that if bad
borrowers are the ones who have an
inclination to borrow because they don't
tend to pay the loans back,
the whole market for loans can be
screwed up and it's similar.
Arguments have been applied to
secondhand cars.
Similar arguments apply in the labor
market to those arguments.
They reshaped economics in the 1970s and
eighties and Joe Stiglitz is one of the
three men who gained recognition for
them at the moment.
He's a professor at the Columbia
Business School in New York.
He also chairs the Brooks World Poverty
Institute at the University of
Manchester.
Uh,
so good academic good policy maker.
Now I don't want to put British
economist is down.
We did have the greatest the world has
ever seen in John Maynard Keynes,
but the Americans,
I'm afraid even how the most fluent
followers of Keynes these days,
and Joseph Stiglitz is one of those like
a formed a format for tonight's going to
be very simple.
He's going to speak for up to 15
minutes.
At that point,
I will stop him,
whatever he's saying.
Um,
I will talk to him a little bit up here.
We'll have some conversation up here and
then we will take questions from the
floor,
but let's get straight on and welcome
professor Joseph stickler.
[inaudible].